we start with Kevin Frazier in Graceland
with the latest on the memorial plans
for Lisa Marie Presley hey there Kev
what's it like down there right now
Rachel there has been a steady stream of
fans here at Graceland leaving flowers
on the wall and writing tributes to Lisa
Marie now behind me final preparations
remade for her celebration of life which
will take place Sunday morning at 9 A.M
hundreds of mourners will be allowed on
the grounds at Graceland to say goodbye
to Elvis's only child
foreign
[Music]
service there will be a procession to
view her final resting place it's here
near the pool in the backyard just a few
feet from her father's grave and next to
her late son Benjamin we've learned his
grave was slightly moved to better make
room for his beloved mother along with
family and friends Elvis star Austin
Butler is expected to attend Lisa
Marie's daughter Riley paid tribute to
her late mom this morning posting this
sweet throwback pick of course it's only
fitting that Lisa Marie is being laid to
rest here at her childhood home Lisa
Marie throughout her adult life
maintained a private area upstairs in
the house you know Elvis was the king
Lisa Marie was the princess and
Graceland was their Castle E.T has
visited the Presley family dozens of
times here and Lisa Marie told us this
estate held so many powerful memories
it's overwhelming you know a little bit
it's like this is your life and all in
one room the exhibits here in include
keepsakes from Lisa Marie's childhood
including her baby shoes tricycle and
old record player I just remember being
you know having it in the middle of the
floor and playing
records E.T was there when Graceland
first opened to the public as a museum
40 years ago the goal to keep Elvis's
Legacy alive and raise money for upkeep
today a ticket costs about 80 bucks back
then it was just five dollars we want to
make it so that people all over the
world can come five dollars may seem not
a lot but I think we're going to give it
a try
[Music]